I'm excited for this one we're going to
talk about feistel networks I love
fossil networks they're brilliant I
they're one of those things in
cryptography where you just think wow
that's very clever that's really elegant
and it's not even that complicated and
yet you just think that's that's great
the fossil network was designed roughly
around the 70s when horst feistel who
worked for IBM who was a german
physicist with the NSA he helped develop
the data encryption standard des right
now des was as we know from a previous
video were placed by aes eventually
mostly because of its short key lengths
but des a structure of des is something
called a feistel cipher or a feistel
network and there are a few of these
around to fish for example is a feistel
cipher 5.so ciphers see use in padding
schemes like the padding scheme used for
digital signatures on certificates
feistel ciphers are used for key
schedules they use for in all over
cryptography and they're very very cool
so I what I wanted to talk about today
all right so a feistel cipher is not
actually a cycle in and of itself it's
essentially a kind of framework for
building encryption algorithms it's a
structure and then you put in some
encryption rounds and a key and things
like this and then it turns it into a
cipher for you and it has some really
neat properties so I'm going to draw it
out and then we'll talk about the
interesting properties that it has
so you start with a block and we're
going to split that block in two and
then we're going to take this as a
right-hand side and this is the
left-hand side we're going to take the
right-hand side down we're going to put
it through some kind of function right
which is going to be some kind of
pseudo-random function like a hash or an
encryption round or something like this
okay take out here we're gonna XOR it
with the left and then we're gonna bring
the left down and we're going to bring
the right down here and this is your
next block
so when you say left you will mean the
left-hand side of that block on the
right-hand side it have to be exactly
half ah very good question so in this
case yes but in general no you have
unbalanced feistel ciphers where the
left and the right are different sizes
but for this demonstration they're going
to be the same size as near as I can
draw it I'm not very good at drawing so
the next round is exactly the same we
take whatever is new right is we bring
it round we
go through f we XOR it with the left and
we come down here like this and so on
and you can repeat this process as many
times you like for however many rounds
and then at a very end after the last
round you flip the output like this now
this is a structure for encryption in a
sense that you can put in any Fe R and
you sort of build yourself a cipher now
this effort obviously needs to be
somewhat reasonable but what's so
incredibly clever about this encryption
algorithm is how you decrypt it to
decrypt using the same faster cipher you
encrypt by putting your block in here it
goes through here it goes through here
it goes through here and it goes through
as many rounds as you want and you get
some output to decrypt it you pick that
up and you put it in the top and you run
it again and even if this F is a one-way
hash function that can't be reversed
that still decrypts it what I mean like
this is this is why I love faster
ciphers so we're just going to do it
we're going to start with Ln R and we're
gonna work through and we'll see that it
does actually reverse itself right which
is just amazing
I mean maybe you've seen a farce inside
for maybe nobis happens like I think
when the first time I learned about this
I thought that is that it's awesome
so let's do this this is the left this
is the right now for the sake of
argument they're the same size in this
one the light is going to come down here
and it's going to go through this
function so we're going to put in a key
into this F and with a lot more secure
to make these a sub key so lots of
different keys for each around so it's
going to be key one this is going to be
key to like this this F is a round
function that combines whatever comes in
with the key and mixes it up and sends
out here this R comes through this F
yeah and it's ex-ored with this l and
this comes down to here so this element
is L X or F with R and K 1 so I mean
that's going to look like gibberish if I
like I said this side is fairly
straightforward the artists come
straight down and turns into and off
like that so let's do the next round
this is going to come down here and go
through here and then it's going to be X
sword with this R so this output here is
our X or F of this which is L I'm going
to run out of space L X or F
of rk1 of k2 like that that is that
right I think it's what maybe it's a
good thing that we didn't do three
rounds or four rounds of this because
this could take me quite a while by hand
this one is going to get copied down so
this is going to be L X or f of r and k1
now both of these will look like
gibberish we're going to switch them
round here
I won't draw them in quite yet right but
this one comes down here and this one
comes down here
feel free to animate it sure thanks for
that okay so now we're going to see how
we can decrypt this back to LMR and all
we have to do is take this put it in the
top and we have to swap our sub keys
around because of course the rounds are
happening in a different order so I'm
going to draw this exact same structure
again on the next piece of paper so that
we have something new to work on
otherwise I'm going to get very confused
so this could be a competition how fast
can you draw a feistel cipher from
memory so go that I mean they're not
nearly wide enough for me to fit myself
in all right let's go again I think
that's what you know so the keys need to
be in a different order so this is going
to be k2 coming in here and this is
going to be k1 coming in here reversing
these keys you know I wouldn't lean not
to much important that will be a list of
data or something like that
very straightforward all right so let's
put let's copy our data our cipher text
in we thought we're going to do do that
and plug them in like this see what I'm
doing right so I'm going to draw them in
to bear with me this one is going to be
over here ah X or F of L X or F are k1
k2 and we'll just pretend that green
eyes a little bit further along okay and
this one is just L X or F of our k1 and
then we're going to see what happens
can you remember what it was that's
really interesting about X or if you do
it again the second time
it's the reversible thing right it's a
reversible thing that's the key to this
whole thing when you ex or something
with the same thing again it undoes it
okay so what happens here is L F of our
k1 is going to come through here and
turn into F of L F of our k1 k2
which is this bit so that's going to
come in XOR with this and we're just
going to get our out again here this
gets copied down here so L X or F of our
k1 so let's go again
our comes in here it becomes F of our k1
X or with this this becomes L or gets
passed down here L goes to here or goes
to here and this will work for any
number of rounds and for any round
function all right which is super cool
and it's going to be a combination of
all of these so this one times this one
plus this one times this one plus this
one times this one plus this one times
this one and then we repeat this process
for each of the values so we're taking
bits and bytes from all of these in this
column jumbling them up moving them
around shifting them and there was a
reverse inverse matrix